nice t-shirt
this might have been worn on purpose
okay it's outstanding
yeah um listen i'm a fan of your work
for a long time i have a lot of
questions let's see how many i can get
through in my time
if someone if someone has actually never
read anything that you've written
what is the place they should start what
is the book they should start with
mystic river or the drop
those are the two that that uh
are the closest to my the voice i grew
up hearing
around me everywhere you know in boston
um i should also mention i am from the
boston area that might be one of the
reasons why um i think maybe your work
is you know why i really enjoy your work
um if someone has actually never seen
uh
any of the films you've worked on or any
of the things that have been made or the
tv
tv is do you have a favor do you have a
thing that you want them to start with
blackbird
exactly good answer um if you could get
the financing to make anything you want
adapt anything
um what would you make and why
i don't know i think maybe to be honest
the thing that i think a lot about is
one of the last books i read the silent
patient
i i think uh but i know the rights are
tied up but i think that might be a
something i would love to take a crack
at
otherwise an adaptation of my book the
given day
which is just too expensive to do that's
another thing you've obviously a lot of
your work has been adapted and uh but
there are obviously some that haven't
been is there one that's getting ready
like is there one that's closer to being
made or is there one that you would
really love to see mate i guess my next
book which doesn't come out until next
spring um i'm determined to make that
myself
as a as a limited television show i
don't believe you've directed anything
is directing something that you're
interested in yeah i'm uh
it's it's been
uh impressed upon me that i should do it
so i'm going to the next tv show that i
run i'll be directing the first two
episodes i think
will it be what you just mentioned no
probably not there's one tv show in
between then that
i
i understand um you worked on the wire a
little bit yes uh what does it mean to
you to have been part of one of the
greatest television shows ever made
it's great because look there's no ego
involved for me i was a cog in the wheel
i was i was doing
uh i was there to advance the vision of
david simon and ed burns and and what a
vision it was and we had a blast
and we were not we were just left alone
because to be honest nobody watched us
we were not the wire until the fifth
season the wire as you now know it until
the fifth season so
we
we
when you're
that's a wonderful place to be i wish
other people other writers i wish that's
on other writers as opposed to
you know we have a viewership of 33
million people in there expecting this
meat and potatoes week after week after
week and you got to deliver it i have no
desire to work for that type of show
that's the thing that no one remembers
uh is that hbo to their credit kept that
show on the air because they knew how
good it was
exactly exactly
um and
and allowed us you know by the time we
got to season four which is our best
moment
um
you know they allowed us to do something
i remember when david walked in the room
and said we're going to do middle school
i thought wow those are the least two
sexy words in history you know um and
that was our season
and
they let us do it yeah i all props to
hbo i i
um i'm so thankful that they allowed
that show to get on the air and kept it
on the air like i said um jumping into
why i get to talk to you today first i
want to start with i've seen all six
episodes congrats on the season
um how did you end up with six episodes
was it ever gonna be four or eight
no at one point i knew i knew i could
never get more than six out of it i knew
that but originally it was five and then
everybody pushed really hard my produce
all my fellow producers uh even the
actors they wanted me to do this one
episode that i didn't want to do
and i'm so glad i did it and and that
was episode four everybody wanted an
episode that slowed everything down and
showed who these guys were so we came up
with the riot the riot's the most
fictional thing in the show there never
was a riot
um but we came up with the riot so that
these guys could really
slow their role and have a major dance
with each other to discover who each who
each other was
and each plays the psychiatrist to the
other which i thought was fascinating
when you are writing and you're writing
say working on a show like this um how
much are you thinking about budget in
the writing process because you've
worked on so many different things and
how much is it sort of like you can't
think about that until you actually you
know you you know what i mean nope don't
think about it don't think about it
until they tell you you have to think
about it i just don't i don't i because
i know that once i write to production
and that means what you're saying which
is they say no you can't have a bus no
you can't shoot out on a date if you
shoot that out on a boat at night it's
going to add three days to our schedule
and we don't have those three days
you know then you write to production
but until that moment i'm riding that
scene on the boat at night
i love
uh loved ray liotta uh just
loved his work and he is exceptional in
this series he he just delivers um like
that diner scene i could keep on
mentioning things yeah what was it like
seeing what he was giving his
performance on this because it's so good
it was it was it was it was a dream come
true i can't say it any other way i had
wanted to write for ray leota since as a
20 year old i saw something wild
and and was like who is this guy
um and uh so when i wrote this script i
wrote it for him specifically no other
actors were in my head for any of the
other parts but for big jim i only
wanted ray liotta
and uh and then we got him and he came
on set
and he was the consummate pro and i'll
tell you one little detail which i
thought was just perfect
ray was not
ray was there he was a pro he was there
to work he wasn't there to make friends
he wasn't there he was just there come
in there and hit his marks and
give you a fresh take on anything and he
would sit there for 16 hours if you
engaged him he was just a a pro but
here's the thing he he was not a huggy
or cuddly guy which is fine i grew up
among non-huddly
non-huggy cuddly guys um so
the first thing he did when he met taran
was hug him
first thing
and it was the first day of their
shooting together and he established
right off the bat a father and son
relationship and that warmth was in
everything they did
that's the type of actor it was what was
it actually about this story and
material that said i want to make this
i'm going to spend a ton of time working
on it
i thought there was two things i thought
there was this really beautiful clean
mythological line and i really wanted to
tell my mythological story my entire
life like i wanted that like apocalypse
now is a mythological story i wanted to
tell that type of story and this is a
clean line there's a callow young man
who was sent out into the world
by the village
to protect them from the monster living
up somewhere in the in the dark he goes
out he goes down through a dark forest
into a dark cave fights the monster
comes back out but now he's a very
changed young man
and that was the story i wanted to tell
and then the second thing was i i was
thinking a lot about toxic masculinity
it's everywhere now
uh and and i thought
how are you gonna find common ground
with a serial killer who is the epitome
of toxic masculinity a killer of women
oh
you'd have to examine your own issues
with women you'd have to examine your
own damage
and
that's that's an interesting story
that's not the story that jimmy
physically the real jimmy king
physically went through this exact story
but psychologically and emotionally he
did not go through that journey that was
the journey that i gave to my character
taryn and paul are both so good and uh
they they have some great scenes
together uh obviously more than just a
few um what was it like actually working
with them and making sure that their
portrayals
um
was what you were looking for and just
like collaborating with them
so taryn
was the first person we brought in and
then taryn was was so committed that he
became an executive producer on the part
on the project and
when you're number one on the call sheet
is is projecting that that level of
commitment that level of lack of vanity
that that level of professionalism
everybody else falls pretty quickly in
line um and we went out uh and committed
to paul after paul auditioned and showed
us some really amazing work on larry in
the darker parts of larry
um and from that point on there was a a
universal collaborative feeling on the
show for everybody not just for all of
our actors um
and and it and it extended
at every step for the entire summer that
we should more than the summer the
spring and summer that we shot the show
um so
i would say working with them was a
was a joy they were open to anything
they could paul does things that are
absolutely things that he and i
conversed about that are not in the
script the one that i i i became very
fascinated with was this concept that
larry
sometimes larry's synapses don't fire
correctly you know um larry was
allegedly uh had an 80 an iq of 80 which
i find impossible to believe
but
sometimes his his synapses wouldn't fire
correctly and
paul plays that
and we decided it would be it's a really
inconvenient times like jimmy's this
close to getting a piece of information
and then larry just he vanishes he just
disappears his brain is misfiring and
then he comes back and he's like i
really like vans
you know
so uh yeah sorry i know i was just gonna
say i agree with you there's no way
larry had an iq of 80 to pull off
everything he did no way no way yeah if
he did he was a savant when it came to
you know what larry may have been
what made what he may be is the only
serial confessor and serial killer in in
history we don't know we can't prove
he's never been he's never been
convicted of killing he's been convicted
of kidnapping so um but
if he was that then then he was laying
the groundwork by confessing to things
that he didn't do
so that when he confessed to things he
did do
nobody would believe him which i think
was part of the game
which is one
sick sick game
yeah and not an iq of 80. um
obviously everything changes in the
editing room and i'm curious how did
this series possibly change in the
editing room in ways you didn't expect
well it actually didn't change um
drastically over overall in the editing
room but where it
completely changed was
uh we had the pilot script and the pilot
script is the only script i've ever
written that was largely left untouched
nobody touched nobody i barely got a
note on it everybody was just like well
done go write the rest of them and then
i would rewrite the other ones but
everybody just left the pilot alone left
the pilot alone left the pilot alone we
went on we shot the pilot
had some trouble with some scenes that
suddenly we were like oh that's an
interesting warning
i rewrote a scene of the pilot we reshot
that scene
went and then we're like oh now we're
okay get back get into editing
all of a sudden we're like this pilot
doesn't work it does not work
and i had to stare at it and stare at it
and watch it again and again and again
and realize
wow
we completely screwed up the opening 15
minutes we have to restructure the
entire tire pilot
so the first 15 minutes work and we did
it worked it was like
but
that was two years of that thing just
floating along nobody noticing any
problems with it until you're in editing
yeah i've heard this from so many
different people uh i'm about to run out
of time with you uh what's the status of
american son
uh it's it's doa it's i mean it's it's
uh it's in turn around it was two weeks
from being uh being shot
and financing fell through
when it's turned around
that sucks well i don't know i mean
profit stands on its own i'm not sure we
need no no no totally but i i mean i i
enjoy your words and i would like to
think that you have a you know
uh anyway um what is what is the next
thing that you are actually going to do
i'm i'm working on a project for apple
now i can't speak to it yet apple tv
but i can't i can't speak to the
specifics yet
i i completely understand i've heard
this from many different people listen i
gotta stop here i'm just gonna say
seriously great talking with you big fan
and i wish you nothing but the best
thank you so much glad you enjoyed the
show love the t-shirt
you